here on the bone here I like examining
the workouts found in anime comic books
and movies to see what's possible
I believe that training should be
exciting and that we should be more
ambitious about our goals we shouldn't
be content to Train like everyone else
but should find ways to express
ourselves and push physical culture
forwards fiction can be a great source
of inspiration that said I hadn't
actually watched Kenichi until some
people started asking me about the
concept of pink muscle this came up
several times in fact so I decided I'd
tackle it as there seems to be some
misunderstanding surrounding how muscle
fiber works oh and guys of course it
wouldn't be right for me to cover this
topic without giving a shout-out to Jax
blade he previously covered kaneki's
training not focusing specifically on
this bit so much and generally he makes
all kinds of anime workouts and they're
really cool so you should go and check
him out if you're interested in that
kind of thing
the idea is this one of Khomeini's
masters called a kisame has converted
all the muscle in his body to what he
refers to as pink muscle this created
the physique comprised of the most
powerful and adaptable type of muscle
with none wasted but Oh like Asami he
ignored conventional wisdom and followed
his own theories he believed that muscle
type could be changed and after 20 years
of bizarre training he had converted all
this red and white muscle to pink so
while he may not look all that strong
what you see is 100% muscle he's like a
rock I doubt that guy has a milligram of
body fat on him
so is this possible well according to
the show there are three types of twitch
muscle fiber solo red fast white and
in-between pink the human body is made
up of three different kinds of muscle
white muscle that's good for fast sudden
moves but lacks endurance red muscle
that's got endurance but not much power
and in between those two is a bit of
pink muscle that's supposed to have both
qualities combined this correlates well
with what we know we have type 1 muscle
fiber
aka slow twitch this is oxidative muscle
fiber that is used for aerobic exercise
like running its sled to contract
smaller in size and produces a less
force however it also allows you to
exert yourself for longer periods it's
more efficient this fiber is indeed red
in color going to the higher oxygen
content then there's type 2x muscle
fiber
aka fast glycolytic or super fast which
these are anaerobic this allows for more
explosive force and speed but also
fatigues much more quickly you use type
2 X during your 1 rep max or when
sprinting at top speed off the starting
block this is incorrectly referred to as
type 2 B by like everyone even my
personal training textbooks finally type
2a muscle fibers aka moderate fast which
are intermediary muscle fibers these are
useful for short durations of more
intensive exercise such as lifting
weights bear less energy efficient than
type 1 muscle fiber but more fatigue
resistant than pipe 2x what a kisame has
allegedly done then is to convert all of
his muscle to the pink type 2a and
therefore achieved the perfect mix of
explosiveness and endurance
unfortunately this time it's entirely
fiction sorry to burst your bubble not
only is this impossible but it also
wouldn't be desirable even if it were
possible but we can take some
interesting ideas from it and use it to
illustrate some things about the human
body as is often the case the fact is in
some ways stranger than the fiction
first the good news contrary to popular
belief you actually can convert type 1
muscle fiber to type 2a moreover a lot
of muscle fiber in untrained individuals
is actually made up from hybrid types
there are two types of muscle fiber at
once training increases specificity by
creating more pure fiber types in
reality they were 10% change would be
considered fairly impressive and much
more than that starts to become unlikely
type 1 muscle fiber is far less prone to
changing type as well so changing all
your muscle fibers to type 2a is
strictly only going to happen within the
realms of fiction and there's good
reason for this you actually need a good
amount of slow-twitch muscle fiber apart
from the fact that slow twitch is what
allows you to run long distances which
even a kisame would presumably need to
do from time to time there's also the
fact that slow twitch muscle fiber works
all the time to keep you upright the
amount of each fiber type varies from
one muscle group to the next while your
biceps consist of a lot of fast twitch
to a fiber just over 50% your abs and
curves consist of a lot more type one
fiber why because your arms hang by your
side all day until we need to use them
often for strength requiring movement or
a very quick movement conversely your
abs are slightly contracted all day just
to keep you upright if you are comprised
of 100% fast twitch muscle fiber you'd
eventually guess out and collapse
because you'd be exerting so much force
just to stay upright it's also
slow-twitch muscle fiber that gives us
extremely fine motor control when you
engage in any movement the brain needs
to recruit two motor units comprised of
muscle fibers these are arranged in size
so that you have some small groups of
slow-twitch fibers and some big groups
of fast-twitch fibers now let's say you
want to move your hand just a millimeter
in one direction during some calligraphy
or disarming a bomb you'll now want to
apply just a tiny bit of pressure and so
you'd recruit just a tiny amount of
extra force from your small motor units
if you only have fast twitch fiber then
your arm will jerk suddenly in that
direction and it's game over
if you want more proof that you need
both types of fiber just consider that
this separation between type 1 and type
2 is seen all throughout mammals
suggesting that it's an evolutionary
imperative the other issue here is that
converting all your muscle to type 2a
would mean losing that type 2x muscle
fiber something that no athlete in their
right mind would want to do actually
most types of training even lifting
heavy weights will change most of your
type 2x fiber to type 2a you only have
extremely small amounts of type 2 X
relative to type 2a this makes sense
given just how inefficient type 2 X is
from an energy standpoint the only time
you need to create more 2 X is when
you're moving extremely explosively such
as when lifting your 95% one rep max for
an Olympic lifts or when sprinting off
the starting block in a race while fast
twitch fiber is 5 to 6 times faster than
slow twitch fiber super fast which is
actually 20 times more powerful those
few super powered fibers make a world of
difference when it comes to your max
strength and speed in short you do not
want to get rid of all of them but what
lessons could we take from Makassar me
one interesting concept is training for
fiber type typically when lifting
weights we will stick with in rep ranges
somewhere between 3 to 20 in all these
cases we are training with type 2 a
muscle fiber predominantly this makes
sense for bodybuilders given that type 2
muscle fiber grows about twice as much
in response to this kind of training
resulting in a more impressive and bulky
physique it makes sense for power
lifters too who can still generate a
huge amount of explosive strength this
way but if the power lifter really wants
to maximize their explosiveness then
they need to train at 95% of their 1 rep
max to encourage the maximum amount of
type 2 X fiber involvement alternatively
they need to maximize their rate of
force
reduction by focusing on the most
explosive movement possible called
compensate reacceleration
this could be combined with plyometric
and ballistic style training at the
other end of the spectrum it may also
make sense to train in a manner that is
going to fatigue the slow twitch muscle
fiber I'm not suggesting combining long
distance mouths and training necessarily
using those long drop sets and super
high rep ranges to fatigue all the
muscle that you can the same goes for
performing yielding isometrics of
failure in other words i'm talking about
getting to that point where you can't
even lift five kilogram dumbbells
anymore or perform even a single push-up
it's only at that point leave the
Teague's are not only the biggest motor
units but also a good proportion of
those slower ones this can increase
capillary density slow twitch muscle
fiber is supplied by a greater density
of capillaries and they can thereby
improve work capacity recovery and more
plus you'll be hitting both types of
muscle fibre with the stimuli required
for growth meaning that you can eke out
just a little extra size if we're going
to imbue a fictional character with the
super powered muscle fiber though then
there is a cooler and more realistic way
that we could do it because locked away
in your genome is the potential for not
three but many different myosin isoforms
these are dormant throwback to our
evolutionary history not normally
expressed by ourselves in theory using
gene doping or some future training
technique that we haven't yet discovered
we might be able to someday unlock this
hidden ancient potential that could
include tapping into the truth type to
be muscle fiber usually only found in
small mammals like mice ever wondered
why mice move in such a jittery and
explosive manner where they can turn the
head so quickly or the same goes for
squirrels or other little critters well
that's thanks to that type to be muscle
fiber and if we could flick that switch
in human muscle we might witness untold
feats of speed explosiveness and
athleticism but for now that also
remains strictly within the realms of
fiction and speculation so if you found
this video useful and interesting guys
if you did then please leave a like and
share it around that helped me out
immensely subscribe to the channel if
you want more like this and if you are
interested in combining unique and
alternative forms of training in order
to achieve unusual results then you
might be interested in my ebook and
training program super functional
training and there's a link to that in
the description down below stay tuned
for more like this hope you guys are all
staying safe and healthy and I'll see
you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now